Hello and welcome!
In the last video about Transformers, we found
out how the Transformer architecture works.
In this video, you will find out
how the transformer architecture
can process images and text simultaneously!
But let’s not spoil everything
already and start with the beginning:
The Transformer architecture has proven
to be very impactful in Natural Language
Processing. But what can be even
cooler than looking at only text?
Well… looking at text and images at the same time!
And because we speak about
two different input types
being processed by a machine learning algorithm,
we are here speaking
about multimodal learning.
Ok, but what does this have
to do with Transformers? Well,
they can be applied to multimodal problems
too, like for integrating vision and language
in an unified model!
How cool is that?
This kind of model has been proposed
almost simultaneously by quite a
number of different researchers.
All these papers proposed almost
concurrently the same base model,
of course with some slight variations,
but with the same basic idea:
They process language and images simultaneously
with a Transformer architecture, and most
often the Transformer architecture chosen is
BERT, a bi-directional version of the Transformer.
And to it, they add the capability of processing
visual input at the same time with language input.
We will not discuss all of the papers here,
you can find a comprehensive list of most
of them linked below, in the description.
Discussing all these papers
would not only take a while,
but because of the high topic overlap,
it would be also quite redundant.
Instead, Ms. Coffee Bean chose her
favorite paper by the Facebook AI team.
She chose this one over all others,
because they provided the code base,
which is not only available for
everyone, but also clean and maintained.
In the following, we will discuss
first how image and language are
integrated at once in the BERT
Transformer model and second about
the training procedure, which I would
like to call “the pre-train-ception!"
Ok, so let’s dive into it!
From now on, we will call this the “Transformer
module”, which is formed like we have explained
in the last video, so it is formed of the
multi-head self-attention layer, the feed
forward layers and the residual connections
acting like information highways between them.
So this everything now is the transformer module.
The trick here is to train the model on
text-image pairs, like images and their captions.
The text part is easy to explain, because it is
exactly like what the usual BERT architecture
does: we feed the word or tokens in
vector representation together after
we added the positional embeddings
or identifiers to these vectors,
so our model is informed about the word
order by these positional embeddings.
And we feed this to our usual
Transformer Module to process the text.
Now let’s put the text part to the side a little
bit and see what we can do on the image side.
We also have to somehow transform our
image into a vector sequence format,
because the Transformer is specialized
for exactly this, sequences. But how?
Well, the idea is: If we combine
vision and language anyway, why not
have an architecture that specializes on finding
correspondences between words and image regions?
Ah! Regions, there we said it,
let’s extract such image regions and
order them in an arbitrary sequence.
We can represent each region by a vector by
employing a CNN-based neural network
that we borrow from computer vision.
Good! We got this far.
Now the idea is to really compute these
correspondences between image regions and the text
by adding the layers that do this computation with
co-attention. Now what does co-attention mean?
Until now, we had attention, we had
self-attention, now we have co-attention!?
Well, while the usual Transformer modules
in green look only at their own branch for
computing attention through self-attention,
the co-attention modules in blue are looking
also at the other branch to compute importance
scores between images and text and vice-versa.
So with co-attention, the image
computes attention based on the
text and vice-versa. For refinement we
add then another layer of Transformers
and another Co-attention layer and another
Transformer module and another… and you get it,
the deeper the better! We're
doing deep learning here ;)
Now the question is, how do we end
this? How do we get to our output?
And what is our output anyway?
Well, it depends what we train the network to
do. It can be just a Multi-Layer Perceptron
followed by a softmax for getting out a score for
example for the similarity between image and text.
This is really dependent on the task and
the whole network can have many of these
output heads, one for each task it is trained on,
and sometimes, it is trained also
in parallel on many different tasks.
So naturally, we have to discuss
what we train this monster to do.
And this Pre-train-ception, how I like to call
it, is a very interesting part! Because like in
every inception, we have multiple stages and
here we are ready to explain what Stage 1 is:
We do pre-training at this first stage on the
text side and on the image side, but separately:
For the text, we have BERT trained
on huge amounts of English text. So
we take that BERT weights and use them
here, to initialize our BERT modules.
Then, the image side has do be also pre-trained
to produce useful features from the images.
Here in the ViLBERT paper,
they have used a Faster-RCNN
architecture useful in object
detection for computer vision.
For the second stage of pre-training, the
ViLBERT paper uses the Conceptual Captions
dataset. They use this one and no other,
because it is huge and contains images
and their captions. And on this Conceptual
Captions dataset, they train the network
that was already trained on English text
further with the following objectives:
One task is to predict labels for
what the image regions might be.
Another training task is
also followed at this stage,
which is masked word prediction,
like in the classical Transformer.
So here the model would ideally predict
"mountain", because it knows from the image
through co-attention layers what
should fall into that place best.
And we are already at the training stage number 3,
where the same model that at stage 1 learned
to process images and text separately,
at stage 2 combines them and "understands"
the relations between text and image,
and is now ready to be trained to solve a task
involving both textual and visual modalities!
Such tasks are for example Visual Question
Answering, where the model is given an image
and a question and it has to provide the right
answer to the question, based on the image.
VilBERT not only beat the
state-of-the-art at the time of
publication on this task, but by a large margin!
Visual Commonsense Reasoning is the better brother
of VQA, where the system has to provide the
answer to the question, but also to give the
reason for the answer, and ideally this reason
is you know… reasoning about the problem and is
not giving a tautologic explanation like: "This
picture is a mountain because it is a mountain",
but rather an explanation that this
image depicts a mountain because it,
the mountain is taller than
the horizon, for example.
Here ViLBERT also achieves
state-of-the-art by a large margin.
Image Retrieval is the task where
given a caption of an image,
the model has to select the right image
that is described by the caption from
a pool of many other images. And surprise,
surprise! State-of-the-art again for ViLBERT.
Phrase Grounding is a more fine-grained
task, but also perfect for VilBERT that
thanks to the co-attention layers learns
relationships between image regions and words,
because here in this task, given a
phrase in the caption, like "mountain",
the system has to identify the
region that this phrase refers to.
And yes, again state-of-the-art for ViLBERT. Yay!
So now that you have seen pre-training in so many
stages, first on text, on images, then on
text and images, and you have seen how this
has helped VilBERT to perform so well on
many downstream tasks, we can safely say
that this whole pretrain-ception, or you know,
different stages or strategies to pretrain the
model before being applied and trained further
on a downstream task, is really, really helpful.
[clap noises]
And because these pretraining
strategies are so cool,
we will spend the whole
next video only about this!
We will discuss different pre-training strategies,
because ViLBERT follows only two
of the pre-training strategies,
but there are others, proposed in other
papers about multimodal transformers.
So we will see these strategies in the
next video, and not only strategies
for multimodal Transformers, but
also for the pure language BERT!
See you then, bye!